on est bien peu de chose et mon amie la
rose me l'a dit ce matin
alors je suis
baptisée 91 je me suis épanoui
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre nouvel
épisode du petit tenir la semaine
dernière nous avons découvert un univers
calme et relaxant la salle snoezelen
cette semaine nous allons retrouver
toute la troupe à la ressource pour voir
où en sont les répétitions et
allez
la séance commence par quelques
échauffements
atout sérieux
et puis
les jeunes enchaînent ensuite avec des
jeux de rôle sur les personnages d'abord
ensemble puis chacun leur tour
et
c'est
maintenant que tout le monde est prêt
passons répétition avec le début de la
pièce sous les indications de marica
reuver
à lui passé 120 euros
le travail se poursuit avec une seconde
scène au programme
et
c'est maintenant l'heure pour marika de
dresser un premier bilan de cette
journée les élèves ont-ils bien
progressé bonjour donc aujourd'hui un
jour de répétition un peu traditionnelle
donc on a travaillé un peu sur les
personnages parce que c'est pas évident
pour les jeunes de rentrer dans un
personnage et puis d'avoir une attitude
aussi un peu passive sur scène donc à
pas avoir par exemple les mains dans les
poches ou les bras croisés donc lâcher
un peu prise est vraiment un personnage
donc ça demande un investissement et
surtout du travail sur le corps donc on
a travaillé là dessus ensuite on a
travaillé sous les 3 premières scènes du
petit émir donc l'arrivée le début la
rencontrant les deux personnages et
ensuite les villageois donc avec la
musique donc c'était vraiment
intéressant on monte ça y est en
puissance et je pense qu'on va y arriver
si marica est satisfaite du travail
accompli les élèves semblent en tirait
également des effets positifs écoutons
sandrine douaniers en compagnie d'amis
bonjour je m'appelle 120 douaniers je
suis monitrice éducatrice donc à lire
samedi la ressource aujourd'hui je suis
venu donc observer emi qui essuient le
projet du petit émir avec marica donc ça
m'a permis d'observer
amy elle a pris de l'assurance elle a eu
beaucoup plus confiance en elle donc
c'est très formateur au temporel et
autant pour nous les éducateurs
donc voilà c'est c'est un projet qui
permet donc à amy de progresser
progressivement et qui permet d'avoir
justement d'être à l'aise devant un
public alors bravo à l'équipe qui met en
place cet atelier l équipe gagne et de
l'éducateur est aussi marica j'espère
vraiment que cela continuer sur cette
lancée
cette journée s'achève donc sur cette
note positive
il est temps pour chacun de rentrer chez
soi la semaine prochaine nous vous
proposerons de partir à la découverte du
métier d'art thérapeute à travers le
portrait de marica